good morning guys today is day two of
the Quan Chronicles of us moving yet
again how many years in a row is that
one two three four years in a row I'm so
excited and that's not even the count uh
before we purchase our first house
before then we were moving a ton we went
from
um a house to Monterey Park and that one
had three different Lots so we went to
each one of those lots
um and then from there we went to
Alhambra from Alhambra we went to
downtown L.A downtown L.A we went to
where do we go from downtown
oh back to Monterey Park then Glendora
then Vegas now leaving
anyway what do I tell you you already
know what's up you already know the deal
here
um but yeah we're cleaning putting stuff
away
um
I don't know what I'm gonna do with all
of this food but
we will eventually take it uh the
downstairs looks like this at the moment
it's a [ __ ] mess but look at this
a bunch of stuff here
this is all our packing stuff and it's
been pretty rad because like any package
I get I save this stuffing and I've been
doing it for maybe the past year or even
longer like whenever I get anything like
any type of gifting or anything I Cass
um yeah been saving it look at that
Amazon boxes I'm being terrific but this
place looks like a vomit Zone
but I think
that's what it has to look like for now
this one's just an interesting move
because we're going from our home to now
an apartment because our other home is
currently being built and it's not going
to be finished until possibly late
September early October
possibly but um
we don't know so I have to like pack
stuff that I don't need for three months
and then I have to put stuff aside for
our everyday living for those three
months so it's kind of like a weird
brain split that I'm doing here
but luckily I have Parts uh Papa my mama
and now we're like
up here
whoa what is that why do you have a blue
uh black light isn't it black well it's
called the black light you know why no
okay
yeah sure me neither
but why but you know why I bought that
for you
so we can look at scorpions
at night time they can be different
cones
so we're working on his room
and it does take a little bit just
because he has clothes that I'm not even
sure fit him anymore so as I'm packing
things and setting things aside
so that I don't put it away for three
months
um I'm having him try on that's why he's
a little naked naked Duty over there
okay naked Duty
yeah and we wouldn't be a Latino
household if we didn't have cleaning
music in espanol and of course it's
happening these are like bangers too
thank you
he froze
[Applause]
the only person that finds moving fun
excuse me sir
excuse me
A Hymn a him
I see something
A Hymn
hello I have parts that over here
helping
glasses
some makeup and I'm working on my room
we got the moms over here putting all
the way all bedding
see some paper that I saved from some
old packages putting away a bunch of my
ridiculous glasses taika's room is
basically done
it's happening this is crazy when bark
from Surprise to be like holy crap you
guys are [ __ ] fast
because after my room
it's the garage and then we're pretty
much packed and now obviously there's
like stragglers and little knickknacks
and stuff but
we're making really good timing it's
only the 30th of July we have to be out
August 15th bro
this is time
okay so a little life hack moving hack I
should say not life hack but a moving
hack that I started incorporating and
I'm so happy that I thought of this is
putting all of his jewelry
an individual baggies
so that
in
the
transition
look at that so I went to Amazon and I
picked up a bunch of different little
sizes I think all of this it was like
200 little baggies and it says less than
10 bucks I think
um I got multiple sizes here
3.9 by 5.2 yeah so four different sizes
come in and I get all my little fashion
jewelry
and I put them in the baggies
so that everything's nice and organized
I also like to keep all of my glasses
cases
so I'm so happy I kept all of them
because now I can try for all my glasses
without
risking I'm getting broken
and of course you guys saw the quest box
I'm recycling upcycling
so this is what we'll be using today
s'mores
let me get s'mores okay what's going on
okay monkey we got our ingredients we
got our jumbo
a jumbo marshmallows we got our little
marshmallow they're giant huh these are
massive
and then we got our chocolate
this is chocolate what and the oil ones
oh yeah you want to do the chocolate
ones right yeah we're gonna do this one
look at this one's yummy yummy
[Music]
okay monkey
it's ready
yeah play a player okay let's move over
here
okay let's turn this on that got burned
yeah can you touch this no because it's
hot and you bring your hand it's gonna
be like that yep yep great answer is
[Music]
okay it's getting hot let's cut another
one
oh that one was in fact good is that
okay baby
that's it that's it we just need two
crabs just you and Grandma I'm not gonna
have one so here's your little
marshmallow
marshmallow hold on hold on
yes yes one second no you take the bite
once it's Ooey and gooey oh I think we
need plates right or no yeah it's gonna
get melted on our hands okay let's get
the plates go get it yeah thanks dude
oh man this Hershey Kisses for this
Hershey bar smells delicious
so
here is the spread
yeah that's all you need
what you put and we have our fun handy
dandy it's so smart marshmallows
here I'll poke yours there you go thanks
Mama you're welcome baby
it's hot it's getting hot
so don't let it touch the metal okay
because it's gonna melt yeah you want to
go higher
yeah it's getting hot barely oh that's
so close I like that what about this uh
you know what I want to do I want to
melt the chocolate for
why so it could be super gooey for you
guys
an idea could this work probably not
cool you might be you could get a little
bit closer yeah
yeah that works
oh you see it turning red yeah
[Music]
is it changing colors yet nope it's
still at the same clothes what do you
think of the suits good enough to get to
the birthday party is it changing color
no but it smells good huh
okay we're gonna wait for this to warm
up a little bit more and then we'll
start doing it and then
let's try this again
just leave it there I don't think you
have to move it too much just yet I'll
tell you when it's searched
don't touch the I think you could turn
it a little bit
yeah oh look I got a little bit Brown
see yeah
[Applause]
like this I'm gonna do this just to warm
it up for you yeah you can put it there
too we could do it together oh no don't
touch it just like that
oh shoot it's melted really fast holy
moly macaroni
it melted super fast I was not expecting
that
let's go try this they got someone
oh no you put yours too no here baby
like that we could share the flame Mama
move it because it's gonna melt that all
right
what's ready for you look at that look
at that oh it made it out
I can see my whole life is that yummy no
leave it there you have to be patient
like that this is too Brown is that
crazy that's a crazy bones don't get too
far away you want to stay like around
there
turn it a bit
nice just a little bit not too much turn
it
turn it
turn it
get in the middle you want to go in the
middle like that yeah
[Music]
yeah I think this is happening too slow
for him
good job here I'll hold it for you
you tell me to turn it
turn let me see it let me see it okay
[Applause]
yeah I'm only turning it slowly oh
tell me the turn I'm gonna turn a little
bit
go up go up it's too close too close to
the metal got it should I turn it yeah
wow yummy yummy this is gonna be so good
dude
who's it who's this one for Grandma oh
you're gonna give her the first bite
no grandma always goes first you always
go last remember yeah
you could switch but this one's still
Grandma's
look at that
oh Grandma's in for a treat
yeah give me for my eyeballs
yeah I know that sounds gross I'm not
gonna eat with my eyeballs I'm just
saying I wish I could eat it with you
guys this looks delicious I'm not eating
that after dinner
it's okay I'm a cool Mom
[Music]
oh look at that
yard I wish I was a cool one and I am
yeah do you think I'm cool yep okay now
we gotta do the Smasher room okay go
smash it oh no oh that was close that
was close oh my God wait don't smash too
much foreign
okay let's give it to Grandma look at
this give it to Grandma don't smash it
anymore whoa It's a massive one that's a
crazy yeah this is Grandma
what's sliding
see spaghetti
so taika made his could you help me with
what I cannot pick it up because it was
at the bottom it's okay
make a mess
make a big mess
is it perfect yeah lick your fingers
it's all good bye oh man let's go wash
your hands let's go
okay then I don't know what to tell you
but look at this
oh my God
oh that sounds so good
can you guys make some in my honor
thank you
excuse me sir who are you
hey worker man why are you a worker man
oh because you have tools is that your
worker truck
what about your hat what is that called
a worker hat I couldn't have guessed it
you big cutie guy you ready to go to bed
you little stinky butt
but they haven't smelled it I am stinky
that's someone take a shower you're
gonna take a shower
yeah you are stinky butt
you've been wearing that underwear for
two days
gross
yucky yucky
and these are all his little friend
lineup so all so these two guys are good
guys
this guy the rat is a bad guy
the mid uh Tom is a good guy the guy
with the bean is a bad guy Mickey's a
good guy
and this is the Beloved monkey Cheeto
he's a super good guy what
it's for the pool table
[Applause]
yeah leave them in there please oh oh he
discovered some stuff okay well on that
note
you guys
for your
love and support I'm about to go to bed
I am exhausted
good night
this guy's exhausted too good night
good night see